hello welcome to this video playing
chahal probably it's not the real
pronunciation but I cannot cannot do any
better so let's go on Queens gambit push
perform yeah let's see if a flight I
really have to refresh my knowledge them
I'm absolutely i'm still playing a line
there that is quite outdated with seat
XD 522 is supposed to be better but I
don't know the details I mean this line
is not bad but it is not as promising as
them on current main lines that was some
in fashion like maybe eight to ten years
ago nowadays i think is pretty pretty a
satisfactory for black
okay so we've got this traded try to
play rugby one increase the pressure an
interesting position type arises out to
deform after which I can well normally
white goes in for which is some the
interesting position type I was
referring to and here I'm actually feel
slightly tempted to just take my kids
it's it's very dry sure if i take very
dry ok so I rooked you won Queen d7 I
actually think is surprising due to a
number of reasons Bishop g5 isn't is a
move now after which he has to go f6 i
also have 95 and this is what i'm going
to play just trading stuff and it's not
close to playing d4 here absolutely not
okay so probably here Queen B 6 is an
idea so he's giving up a pawn very very
likely he would have enough play for it
so rook c8 hooks the 825 takes takes
rook c3 at the end yeah that is very dry
maybe this is a little bit more
challenging yeah I thought up to five
now is a little bit more why is he just
moving the Queen that's possible I Queen
to e6 number 24 yeah it's a pawn rook c5
rock t7 should give me slide winning
chances rook a 3 there is a 4 I thought
and have chances to win the second porn
and in fact I don't see how he is not
losing a second porn at the mode
so look these six let's look a three
okay v6 is a good enough I think okay I
can check on the 8th 1st and look to d6
hmm that stuff it's still to draw
unfortunately
Jeff hmm okay
Yahoo p8 it's still a draw maybe you're
up to five trying for maybe this is
still giving I mean it's probably a
drawing you Avett maybe this is giving
some additional problems ideas 85 now it
is also drawn yeah but okay it's just
how it is with many book endings check
time warning
check yeah it's not much to not much to
say you can just stay check three
against two it's a very dry chef
yeah just the drawn can play room car
look to the fifth for example check
check check game drama yeah the drawing
margin is very high in those rogue
endings hmm yeah it's a bit
disappointing from this position but
it's them it's probably the best that I
can get like that this is this is going
to be liquidated and then you will draw
with four against three I tried a little
bit with this taking with the poem maybe
maybe this is a medium yeah i mean i can
do this and we have basically the same
position as in the game this is going to
be traded and then four against three
years a draw it's not not much to do the
double porn is no problem at all of em
now maybe I still should have tried that
but with a true g for him coming up I
can go g5 and f6 probably and it's still
very comfortable yeah it's just a draw I
tried the jump it with those poor news
but today they actually they don't
change at all the situation is really
also not much that you can do the
computers are constantly miss evaluating
the situation here by the way if you
give it to an engineer god stop version
the background it gives a 1.6 which is
ridiculous it's completely dead this
position and nothing happens here yeah
okay anyway that was a pretty correct
draw I think I mean it felt like I
should get more about sir
I didn't didn't get anything okay well
thanks for watching